what's up fellow Geeks we have something
special from Dr collector we have the
indominous Rex premium statue straight
from him and she looks amazing let's
open her up and also I need to make
mention that this is number 64 out of
350 statues made for this so you know
this is exclusive and if you want to get
one for yourself this thing goes for 465
USD check the link in the description
below to get one from Sideshow and yeah
let's get to opening this up so at the
front we've got the Jurassic world logo
and on the side as well and at the back
we have a nice pre view of what's to
come when we open up the indominous Rex
and of course the full bust on this side
it's got to be real careful this thing
uh she's made of poly resin so just keep
that in mind all right hold
on so just be mindful of the directions
it says bottom here so at the front of
the cyr box we have the doctor
collector's logo
let's lift this up ooh so the main bus
is down here and there is one append
that you do need to stick on it's
included in the Box as well of course
and let's just take this out so this is
a claw and there's a single magnetic bit
on the side here all right let's grab
the bust up right now it's a bit Hefty
it's about 5 kg okay so this is Madame
indominus so one thing to note about the
bust is that we got a pretty tight
version and by that I mean the little
hole that you're going to slot the claw
into isn't exactly form fitting so
you're going to need to put a little bit
of back into pushing the claw inside but
of course be careful and don't fret if
some of the paint comes off the little
appendage on here we've got paint That's
chipped off already so let's just put it
inside just do it very slowly all right
and we're in all right so to kick things
off of course you've got the indominous
Rex down here her Claw is scratching at
the sides and you just got little Flames
down here I kind of wish they had LEDs
going on and and this thing was like
either battery or USB operated because
there'll be a really nice touch if they
actually lit up little flame bits down
here and of course the Jurassic world
logo very nice addition to the top but
what I like the most about this bus
isn't even the dominous but the little
Fallen Banner for Jurassic world at the
bottom this is a great touch it just
shows the dominance that the Dominus has
over the park because you know she's
really like the alpha Alphas except she
got um yeah she got she got eaten up so
her main scales on here are pretty sharp
and the base scales at the bottom they
feel really good however the only thing
I will note is that the eyes aren't
exactly painted what I've noticed that
like if you look close enough like if
you go really close you can see some
pixelation in the eye and I think what
they've done is printed out the eyes and
kind of stuck them in there and then put
glass over it so that's something that
you should know I'm guessing but from
afar and honestly like even if I'm this
close it looks pretty good and the front
here we have indominous Rex this thing
is stenciled in so you've got nice
little texture on here at the back we
have the Dr collector's logo and the J
World logo and at the base of the bus we
have the number of the statue that we've
got again we have number 64 out of 350
if your kid or you loves dinosaurs and
Jurassic Park you're going to love this
bus it's an amazing addition to your
collection and man I kind of wish I had
one at home as well if you have any
questions about the bus let me know in
the comment section down below and I'll
do my best to get to them make sure to
follow us on all of our socials right
here to keep up to date with all the
news that we put out we update content
daily and of course if you haven't make
sure to like And subscribe to us it goes
a long way in keeping the lights on here
so without further adoo I hope you have
a great week this is in and I'll catch
you all
[Music]
soon